One thing I campaigned on was that it's
unconscionable,
that higher education has gone two and a half times more expensive over the last
number of years. And one of the jokes I used to pose was like,
has it gotten two and a half times better? And that always got a laugh.
Cause people were like, it has not really gone two and a half times better.
And then I pose the question to the folks in the audience and was like, Hey,
why has it gotten so expensive? And then they think about it for a minute.
And then I say, did we hire lots of professors? And they're like, no, you know,
did we build lots of new buildings? And they were like, maybe.
And then I say that the real driver is the fact that we've hired
150% more non faculty administrators, uh, at these universities,
they become these like overgrown, uh, bureaucracies themselves.
And it's become this hidden tax on people on the middle-class on folks who are
trying to, to, uh, give their kids a better life. Uh,
and that's been building up for decades in part because any,
any college every year just looks around and says, okay,
how much are we going to increase our prices by this year? And so you have this,
this inflationary effect that's unique to healthcare and education.
And then family has felt like they had no choice but to pay.
So then the government said, don't worry about it. We've got you.
Here's some loans. So when we're now up to 1.6 trillion in student loan debt,
and I love the fact that you work for NYU,
but you're honest about the fact that look,
these university administrators have very clear financial incentives like
foregoing $400 million in tuition is like, uh, you know, like it, it,
it would wreck, um, many of these institutions.
And so you have many schools that are bravely putting up, uh,
signals saying, well, Hey, we're going to reconvene in the fall.
And then you look at it and say like,
is this what you would do if this wasn't like an existential problem for your
school to forgo a tuition revenue for a semester.
And I would love to hear your ideas on how we can somehow help the
university system become more
cost-conscious and invest in things that will actually improve kids' educational
outcomes, as opposed to their us news and world report rankings.
We are definitely brothers from another mother. I mean, we, we, your summary,
it took me two years to get to the, to the summary.
You just articulated in about three minutes, but look,
we live in a capitalist society and having more money means more opportunity for
your kids access to better healthcare access, to a broader selection of mates.
It's just a wonderful thing to have more versus less money in a capitalist
society.
And all of us fall victim to that in the sense that when it's your
first and foremost, going to fix your own oxygen mask.
And there's the belief that universities are these very noble institutions where
we wear cardigans, watch PBS and pet our Labrador.
And don't think about money and professors and administrators want the same
economic security as everyone else.
So by a combination of this dictum or this gestalt,
where everybody has to get a college education,
where we constrained supply and become luxury brands,
as opposed to public servants,
we consistently have been able to raise prices through this kind of cartel.
As you mentioned, twice as fast as inflation.
And we justify that we're doing it for the right reasons,
but the reality is many universities,
especially elite in universities have become hedge funds that provide classes to
the children of their investors.
And then we wipe Vaseline over the lens of the caste structure that has been
that higher education has become by letting in some freakishly remarkable
middle-class and lower income kids and to try and make ourselves kind of the
Neosporin of our guilt. This is it's, it's, it's morally corrupt.
And it is, it is the spring used to be a time of nervousness,
but excitement about where your kid was going to college.
Now it's become a despair and anxiety around.
How do I tell my little girl that Ana fireman
salary, and maybe, I mean, my wife is,
my wife is a doctor, a nurse that we can't afford to send her to Tulane.
How do you have that conversation? How do you,
how do you feel like you're failing the American dream?
Because you can't afford after working your off to income and you can't afford
to send, or you make a worst decision, and that is your kid.
Doesn't get into the top school because they take pride in rejecting nine out of
10 applicants and worst.
Yet they go to a second tier school where they don't get nearly the upside
because corporations still look at those universities in terms of evaluating
your currency in the marketplace and how much they're going to pay you,
but you incur elite university level debt. It just,
this is one of the most, in my opinion, ugly parts of our society right now.
And it's happened incrementally because like anyone else, university,
administrators and professors want to live the same great life as anyone else.
What do we do about it? I've been spending a lot of time with chancellor block,
who is the chancellor of the,
of my Alma mater the receives more applications than any university in the
world. And that's the university of California Los Angeles.
And I've come to the conclusion that these institutions are almost
constitutionally incapable of cutting costs between
tenure, between the Rolex suffocation of their facilities.
It is very hard for them and they haven't had to cut costs for 40 years.
It's almost impossible.
What we could do is through a mix of small and big tech,
potentially potentially dramatically expand capacity.
If you were to take 50% of your courses online,
and there are a lot of courses that would be fine online,
or a lot of sessions where there isn't a lot of interaction that you could
facilitate online. If you take half your classes online,
you effectively Andrew double the size of the campus.
So what I would like to see and what I would hope, individuals like you,
that might serve in a cabinet or be in a position of,
of authority and power someday as could we have some sort of grand bargain where
we go to governor's, let's go to governor Newsome and say,
increase the university of California budget by 20%.
And we're going to dramatically decrease the cost per student
educated through the use of small and big tech by expanding our capacity.
And we're going to take UCLA back from a 13% admin rate to where it was in the
nineties, 20 or 25.
We have to dramatically expand our land grant,
public universities capacity, such that we can take good,
maybe not remarkable. I mean, I don't know where you went to school. I was an,
a remarkably unremarkable kid.
And the reason I'm here speaking to you today is because UCLA led in a third of
its applicants.
And they could say to the son of a single immigrant mother who lived and died,
his secretary, let's be honest. You're not great, but we like your profile.
You're a son of a mayor of California. We're going to let you in.
They don't have the luxury of doing that. Now.
They don't have the luxury of letting in kids with remarkable futures.
They have to only let in the remarkable.
So I think it's about dramatically expanding through the use of technology,
freshmen seats,
and also breaking this wheel where academics and
administrators have become drunk on exclusivity. Andrew, every year,
the deans of the top schools,
including mine get up and boasts that we rejected 88% of our applicants.
That's tantamount to the head of a housing shelter,
bragging that he or she turned away nine and 10 people who showed up last night,
we have lost the script. We need to move back to being public servants,
as opposed to luxury brands.
And we need to embrace technology and have almost like a Marshall Marshall
act like feel such that we take capacity for our great
public systems, university of Texas, Michigan university of California,
Cal state, CUNY,
Florida state systems and drummer and expand their seats by 30 or
50%. I think a crisis is a terrible thing to waste.
I think there's an opportunity here to move back to where we were,
where kids who are unremarkable have remarkable opportunities through the upward
lubricant that is higher ed.
Like we, we need to examine this from soup to nuts. Like you look at it and say,
okay, why is it four years? Why does it cost this much?
And to your point, like, why are you getting rewarded for turning people down?
Like, aren't you supposed to be a public good.
I love the fact that you've identified public universities as the place to
launch this from, because it makes the most sense. And,
and they should be growing their seats.
Like instead of a proportion of people you reject,
it should be looking up society wide and saying, okay,
how many 18 year olds do we think are like approximately,
uh, the right fit for what we're going for in terms of a public education.
And then you should be rewarded for educating a higher proportion of those
people, which is like the reverse of the way they get rewarded. Now,
if I'm in position to do this man, I'm a hundred percent going to do.
Yeah. I like it. It comes down to a basic theme in, in a, in a shift in mindset.
And that is the, the worth of a society.
Isn't the opportunities that offers.
It's remarkable that it feels to me like the United States.
And I'm curious to get your has moved from how do we give our truly remarkable,
remarkable being people who are born with tremendous opportunities and also are
tremendously skilled in everyone says NYU is a place for rich kids.
Yeah. But it's also rich kids who are super impressive. They're remarkable.
Do we just continue to follow more and more of the spoils to that small segment
who are both blessed, cause they're born into wealth and be very good,
remarkable, or isn't the judge of a society or the worth of his society.
What kind of opportunities it gives to its unremarkable?
What kind of opportunities it gives to the kid who maybe doesn't have access to
the test prep that you were offering,
who maybe has had challenges at home who maybe doesn't at the age of 15,
doesn't have a patent and isn't building Wells in Africa and isn't captain of
the lacrosse team. I mean, the kids that now get into these schools,
we're basically saying that the two,
the two cohorts that are going to divide the spoils of American productivity
wages have not gone up productivity,
skyrocketed that's trillions of dollars in surplus wealth.
That all goes to two cohorts.
That's the children of rich kids or people who are freakishly remarkable between
the ages of 15 and 17 who get into Harvard. We talk about these elite schools.
The reason we talk,
I talk about the state schools is the IVs are more spectacle than historic.
They educate, they have 64,000 total students.
Ohio state has 55,000 Florida state has 75,000 Berkeley will
graduate more kids from a low-income household this year than the entire Ivy
league combined. So the Ivy league look fine.
You're you're great leaders produce leaders children's of rich kids and
remarkable kids from middle and lower income households.
But we're on America changes where men are Rekha,
fundamentally changes is these land grant public schools that educate two
thirds, two thirds of our students.
And we're going to need some sort of real dramatic rethinking.
I think this is your platform. I think UBI and education.
I think these are the two legs of the stool. I don't know what the third one is.
Andrew for your next run.
You have to say health care. Everyone.
You have to say health because healthcare has some of the similar problems.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.